THANK YOU.
>> MY PLEASURE.
>> Tucker: WELL, SPEAKING OF
CHAOS, LAW ENFORCEMENT HAS BEEN
SUSPENDED AT OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER, WHICH IS WIDE OPEN.
AS A RESULT LAST MONTH ALONE,
U.S. OFFICIALS REPORTED NEARLY
200,000 ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS AT
THE BORDER, JUST THE ONES BEING
COUNTED.
BY COMPARISON, AT THE END OF
2020, MIGRANT ENCOUNTERS TOTALED
72,000 PER MONTH.
SOME OF THESE PEOPLE ARE USING
MILITARY-STYLE CAMOUFLAGE TO
ENTER THE COUNTRY, WHICH IS
BIZARRE.
>> TUCKER, WE'VE SEEN ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS USE ALL TYPES OF
METHODS TO DISGUISE OR
CAMOUFLAGE THEMSELVES.
NOW NEW PICTURES APPEAR TO SHOW
SUSPECTED ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
WEARING GILLEY SUITS TO BLEND
INTO THE DESERT.
BORDER PATROL AGENTS IN THE
EL PASO SECTOR ARRESTED THE
THREE MIGRANTS IN SOUTHERN
MEXICO.
GILLEY IS A TYPE OF MATERIAL
THAT BLENDS INTO NATURAL
ENVIRONMENTS.
MILITARY POLICE, POLICE, AND
HUNTERS USE THEM.
FOX NEWS REACHED OUT FOR MORE
INFORMATION ON THOSE PICTURES.
THIS WEEK THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
ANNOUNCED THERE WERE 199,000
MIGRANT ENCOUNTERS AT THE BORDER
IN JULY.
FOR A COMPARISON, AT THE END OF
2020, MIGRANT ENCOUNTERS WERE
AROUND 72,000 PER MONTH, NOW
SKYROCKETING TO NEARLY 200,000
LAST MONTH, BRINGING TOTAL
NUMBER OF ENCOUNTERS TO A RECORD
1.94 MILLION THIS FISCAL YEAR,
BUT SOURCES TELL FOX NEWS THAT
NUMBER IS NOW OVER 2 MILLION.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION CLAIMS
THE NUMBER OF ENCOUNTERS IS
INFLATED UNDER TITLE 22
EXPULSIONS WHERE MIGRANTS
QUICKLY CROSS BACK INTO THE U.S.
AFTER BEING EXPELLED UNDER THAT
COVID-19 ORDER.
AS WE'VE BEEN REPORTING, STATES
LIKE TEXAS AND ARIZONA ARE
MOVING MIGRANTS TO OTHER STATES,
IN CITIES LIKE WASHINGTON, D.C.
AND NEW YORK, AS A FORM OF
PROTEST TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
TUCKER?